satan brusque et mon corps cette petite
cascade improvisé mais qu'en est-il de
celle là je vous est gracieusement
offert une chaîne secondaire avec que du
gaming dessus mais ça ne vous suffit pas
le soir en baladant sur les commentaires
de mes vidéos pour lire les retours de
ma communauté qui est la meilleure
communauté du monde je vois certains qui
avec regret annonce qu'il manque du
gaming qu'il n'y ait même plus de gaming
sur cette chaîne youtube pourquoi s
arrêter de faire du gaming
car je suis une merde sur les jeux une
merde colossal titane s ok sur une
échelle de mcfly carlito à gotaga je
suis sur mac faye carlito je vous jure
j'ai régressé mon gars de la nouvelle
vague là les gens comptent 12 ans en
cave sur fois en a qui font 28' par jour
les galets laissez moi en fait laissez
moi en faire juste ça fait des mois que
je n'ai pas fait un tapage est jugée
moins confiance en moi j'ai une perte de
confiance en moi depuis ça vraiment donc
je ne louperais sa maman de souffrance
et de venir au monde souffrance mais je
veux bien essayer une dernière fois sur
cette chaise j'ai créé un nouveau
concept pour cela qu'ils s'appellent le
plus change de battle royal voilà comme
ça je peux pas mettre la faute sur le
jeu dire qu'il est nul et c'est non je
change de jeu à chaque fois si j'arrive
pas faire toi fin c'est que je suis une
merde qu'il faut que vous l'admettrez
tout comme moi j'ai mis un peu tôt à
l'admettre et qu'on passe à autre chose
qu'on tourne la page
j'aime ici battle royale deux côtés
unanimes et jennyfer nay de dents je
vais jouer au cices j'ai donc si chance
pour faire top a aujourd'hui sous vos
yeux et pour continuer le gaming sur
cette chaîne youtube vous savez tous
très bien j'ai fait pas la différence
c'est que moi j'ai aucun problème avec
le fait que je le ferais pas mais vous
vous aviez tellement confiance en moi me
suivait depuis si longtemps m'a vu jouer
à temps de jeu que vous vous attachez à
ça le skill laissez-le il est allé
ailleurs il a rejoint d'autres gens il
ne veut plus de nous alors laissons le
en paix commençons avec le battle royale
à l'âme
apex légende j'ai jamais fait une [ __ ]
de gamme de jeux mais j'ai fait le tuto
pour pouvoir jouer sachez que mon pull
chaud grâce aux fermetures à tout moment
jaer mon corps ok c'est un très petit
teasing pour quelque chose qui aura un
grand impact durant toute cette vidéo
sachez le ballon joue on y va car je
prends lui j'ai vu que tu as gars qui
jouent et louis alors je prends lui j'ai
le même gouvernement qui a un enfant de
12 ans qui élève de côté assez bon pour
vous le mec mec c'est ma première game
tu va m'aider durant cette épreuve
yes je suis pas les gars je suis très
heureux de jouer avec vous aujourd'hui
j'espère qu'on va tout donner comme à
lennik sont beaucoup moins optimiste que
moi ok osk essai clermontois qui va nous
car il s'est clairement toi on me dit
souvent que je la vois de mars et je
sais baguette mais vous mais je connais
pas le jour c'est horrible on va ou bon
marché vous marchez sait où le marché c
ou c ou c juste en bas la suède en bas
là on est beau les gars on est bon on
est beau
j'ai une grenade à moi je regarde
je mets le leur devoir comme ça on est
bien nous derrière c'est avec eux que je
faire stopper n'y aura pas besoin de
lancer deux autres les gars je relate on
va t'aider
il y avait une bête de gaulle
non les gars je vous aime courageuse
je vous avez vous étiez la meilleure
squat du jeu je suis vraiment très si
c'était super cool je t'aime volée j'ai
trop triste pourquoi je me suis mis
cette contrainte à chier quoi eh ben moi
je suis heureux de la crise autres parce
que quand je meurs je change de mains ok
c'est parti pour le 2e bataillon royal
farming simulator let go hôpital quoi je
dirige à paris à are to city attend que
le salaire kouassi géant glider un bmx
ou ingrat par vaincre un parti rép
tu verras pmi qui sont la grappa on
commence avec un pompe c'est agréable ça
commence plutôt bien il faut le
souligner à samedi c'est après avoir
chargé immédiatement je sais pas quelle
armée bien qu'elle remet pas bien sachez
le satyre les premières balles
je vais aller là bas faut que j'aille
là-bas la baby gym et nissan a convaincu
une vie réception sur le parasol il
escaladé la clôture
il se dirige à temps le grappin c'est le
moment de tester
je suis en infraction total est morte
est mort obama la grotte croatie je me
tue sa sacoche c'est squeeze qui l'a tué
va mal dormir pendant des semaines
[Musique]
je vais me 0 balle je suis un moine
posture j'ai un problème dans les jeux
j'ai une visibilité très réduite en fait
j'ai vraiment des problèmes de personnes
âgées alors je ne suis pas âgées c'est
un vrai problème dans ma vie à toronto
ayant brûlé et embrouillé la manière
suivante
non non la bidu sur la tête
[ __ ] de merde ça va si vite je suivais
nerfs ce puits n'a aucun sens ce pull a
moins de sens que cette vidéo
ok c'est parti sajoo set live madame
vous m'avez mis dans une guerre où il ya
7 mais quand non c'est un sketch en fait
personne de jouer à ce jeu annoncé le
prêt c'est le lobby avant que la game se
lance bon je suis un demeuré alors on va
aller là à là c'est bien la biche qui je
connais bière heineken hugh coltman ne
suis pas [ __ ] une hache [ __ ] mais je
la trouve ou tâche moi j'ai lâche aux
places à moi tout ça c'est à moi voilà
homme et il est donc une aide mais
regarder l'eau auquel j'ai trouvé une
carte qui va m'amener à un coffre aux
trésors est ce que j'aime l'argent oui
vous le savez vu les op que je fais
alors je vais y aller
attends je suis trop fort mais qu'en
fait je veux juste aller prendre mon
coffre
je prends mon coffre le mec je vais
l'ignorer pour que je perde la vie je
dois zones radioactives faut que vous
dites vous que je devine faut que je dis
des ddd dit yes merci je me casse c'est
quoi ce délire de radioactivité là ils
sont partis on colmate les devs non pas
t'es mort si jamais on peut tellement
bon c'était prévisible
est-ce que je joue avec des bottes à
tous je joue tout simplement avec des
bottes s'expliquera tout c'est quoi ça
aussi aux tiens tu m'as patch et étayent
un petite merde à petites merdes de
campeurs bah moi je vais trouver mon
gars et sais pas à combien de temps pas
j'ai fait ce mois-ci ce héros absolument
ciolos le premier duel il met en place
le premier duel même en pls imams [ __ ]
je me casse a donné l'impulsion en 14
secondes c'est quoi dans ma zone à l'eau
je suis là je comprends rien à voir qui
remet klein clément attend tout ça pour
ça vraiment là tout c'était de la merde
c'est bon c'est clair
oh [ __ ] il me plaît tu là il est beau
il est fluide si j'adore je vous jure je
le sens mes gars bien ça devienne des y
aura pas un code d'un coup avec moi qui
meurt ça n'arrivera pas pas sur ce jeu
là il ya un an et demi mais il est là je
vais piquer ses morts en tout cas j'ai
fait un kill pour moi c'est un top à ce
que j'ai le droit de dire ça ou est-ce
que c'est trés défaitiste a d'abord
regardé qui m'inquiète c'est que le gars
je les tue est très très il va m'arriver
la même chose et la boule de poils ciao
mon pote
oh là là ce que je lis mis ce pauvre
type mais qu'on n'est plus de 17 à temps
mais je me régale sur ce jeu est ce que
c'est parce qu'il est vraiment bien où
est ce que c'est parce que les gens sont
nulles et du coup moi je me sens fort et
du coup j'aime le jeu a peut-être un peu
des deux ma foi pas toi y'a des gens pas
loin on fait du tout faut que sois bon
je fais les attentes d'air une maison
ils seront pas un mec là bas
c'est bon j'ai fait ça mais pourquoi il
n'a pas réagi il avait peut-être pas de
snipe le pauvre il est en galère
oh mon pauvre type on est huit la
cellule nuit meilleurs joueurs qui sont
là je vous jure ce matériel un potentiel
incroyable la mecque la tendance pas
juste ça c'est ça c'est très juste un
mec tout ce qu'il a ce matin j'ai jamais
vu à kkb automne stuff de ma vie mais
que c'est bon on a une passoire sur la
tête gros meilleur baird de l'année
arrêtez de cette musique a pour but de
stresser elle n'a aucun effet sur moi tu
vois pas que ça marche par la coupe la
moque même il a sauté la ce chien
pas comme ça très bon jeu on n'a pas de
ce genre qui a été fait pour un 1er
avril et qui est juste trop bien j'ai
adoré jusqu'à ce que ce groupe connard
de ces morveux tu bien sûr tu ne feras
jamais top 1 à à à
tu ne feras jamais top 1 à 1 le
cinquième je ne marche pas les serveurs
sont dawn est ce un signe du destin ou
simplement une coïncidence n'est pas la
réponse à cette question et c'était le
passage de plus chiant de la vidéo alors
je m'en excuse
allez on y va il est temps de jouer à
apex et non pas à pécs
ce qui serait bien moins drôle je suis
en battle royale doubt c'est quand tu
fais un burn-out parce que tu as trop
jouer au battle royale et surtout trop
perdu c'est maintenant il y aura-t-il
encore du gaming sur cette chaîne c'est
maintenant je dois le mériter en être
capable
alors vais-je faire ce [ __ ] taux qui
va à jamais marqué le youtube qu'un
français voire mondial je suis fatigué
allez faisons soit pas allé un pack à
ouvrir le temps est bon signe c'est bon
si ça
celle là c'est la bonne celle là c'est
la nôtre statistiquement stephen hawking
la trouver sur 30000 viennent de battle
royale vous ferez un taux par minimum
c'est la 38e c'est maintenant
c'est maintenant il ya juste une squad
qui a mieux géré son atterrissage que
nous mais c'est maintenant
wait for me and coming to save you c'est
ça qu'on veut c'est ça qu'on veut c'est
une soit soudée qui s'écoute qui
communiquent exactement comme on est en
train de faire il m'a fermé la porte au
nez pendant que faisait un discours
motivant c'est fou égalé gallega attend
mais j'allais donner du shield et et
soumah je vais les manger
la ligue 1
[Musique]
waouh
voilà c'est pour ça que je sais qu'à
chaque fois que j'en fais la fin est
décevant de la finalité de se vanter nul
et nul à chaque fois je remets ma
seconde peau vous voyez comme j'ai leur
minable c'est votre faute
voilà pourquoi je ne fais plus de gaming
car j'ai moins de plaisir à jouer aux
jeux vidéo car je suis moins bon
qu'avant tout simplement car j'ai moins
envie de jouer c'est un cercle vicieux
est ce que cette phrase a du sens je ne
sais pas a analysé la fête une vidéo
réponse à ce quizz et vous analysez
cette phrase un bon moyen de faire de
vue à terme et sur 10 km
avant je faisais troisième j'avais un
bon là je suis dit gay mais j'ai même
pas un copain allez c'est chiant on met
fin la vidéo maintenant je pars dans un
trou aux casseroles et sharp
[Musique]